OK, so picture this.
You're in Barovia, a land just
soaked in mist and shadow, where
the night itself feels like a
predator.
A small band of heroes is
tearing through the streets of a
town called Valaki, and they're
not just running for their
lives, they're carrying the body
of their friend who's already
fallen.
They are being hunted.
And what's hunting them?
It's a barbed devil, a literal
fiend from the Hells.
And it's howl is this
nightmarish sound of pure
torment.
It's chucking Hellfire at them
while they're scrambling away,
with the party's fighter Radley
just struggling to carry their
dead cleric Traxador.
The devil is getting closer, You
can feel it.
They're completely out of time
and fresh out of ideas.
And right when you think it's
all over, just as Hope is about
to completely flatline, a figure
just steps out of the mists.
This isn't another monster.
It's something else entirely.
Maybe something even more
dangerous.
Yeah, out of all this chaos,
this absolute panic walks a
single man.
And he's just casually tapping
his walking stick on the
cobblestones.
As he gets closer, they realize
who it is.
Rudolf Van Richten, the Monster
Hunter of legend.
His total calm in the middle of
this demonic chase is honestly
just unnerving.
And then Van Richten's calm just
shatters.
He whips a blade out of his
cane, mutters a few words, and
this pulse of shimmering blue
light just erupts from him.
The devil, this massive fiend,
stumbles back.
Its roar is cut short, and it
just vanishes, Gone.
In the ringing silence that's
left, Van Richten just calmly
slides his blade back into his
cane and says.
I wasn't even sure that would
work.
Unbelievable.
Right away, you see Van
Richten's mind at work.
He tells the party, look, you
can't go back to the end.
He's certain their enemy has
invisible spies everywhere, and
going back would get their
allies killed.
Plus, now his own cover is
blown.
His hand has been forced.
The only way out, he says, is
for all of them to flee.
Valaki right now in his wagon.
So the devil is gone.
Great.
But that just kicks off the next
crisis.
The town guard is on high alert
now, and the whole town is about
to go on lockdown.
They have to get out and they
have to get out now.
Van Richten hustles them over to
his old faded carnival wagon,
but something's off.
The Beastmaster Yurihorn has a
Panther with him and it is not
happy about this wagon.
It's growling, it's hackles are
raised, and then the whole wagon
suddenly lurches like something
huge just shifted around inside.
Van Richten has a secret, and
whatever it is, it's locked in
there with them.
There is absolutely no time to
be sneaky.
Van Richten just floors it,
charging the horse street at the
southern gate.
The wooden bar splinters, but a
wheel smacks into the brick
archway and the axle just
shatters as the guards are
slinging spells at them.
Radley and Dermont have to
physically lift the broken wagon
while Van Richten frantically
cast a mending spell, magically
stitching the axle back
together.
It's pure chaos, but they
scramble aboard and peel out
into the night.
So they've escaped Valaki.
Now they find themselves in the
snowy village of Kresk, and they
have one single audacious goal.
They carry the body of their
friend to the Abbey of Saint
Markovia because they're hoping
for an actual miracle
resurrection.
Now the person they're going to
see is called the Abbot.
And get this, he's a celestial
being, an actual Angel who's
been twisted and warped by the
darkness of Borovia.
He's become deranged, obsessed
with this plan to build a bride
for the Land's dark Lord out of
stitched together corpses, A
flesh golem.
This is the holy man they are
pinning all their hopes on.
See, the party had already done
a favor for the Abbot.
They fetched a wedding dress for
his creation.
So in return, he agrees to
perform the ritual.
And you won't believe it.
It works.
Traxxidor is brought back to
life, but death leaves a scar.
He's weak, fatigued.
His voice is soft.
The Abbot explains that the
soul's journey back to the body
is a hard one.
He's alive, yes, but he's not
quite whole.
But this miracle has an
immediate, terrible price.
The local burgomaster sees
tracks that are walking around
alive, and he isn't happy.
He's destroyed.
You see, his own son just died.
And to see the Abbot use this
incredible power on a total
stranger while his own family
line is extinguished, it breaks
him.
He just weeps right there in the
street.
One party's miracle is another
man's deepest tragedy.
All right.
So with their cleric restored,
well, mostly, the party decides
to follow up on a lead Van
Richten gave them.
It points them to a new place, a
new mystery, a decrepit, long
forgotten Manor house called
Argen Vostholt.
The whole journey there is just
creepy.
At one point a massive swarm of
bats just swallows them whole
before vanishing into the mists.
They take this smaller path up
towards the Manor, and what
greets them is this giant silent
statue of a silver dragon.
Now usually silver Dragons are a
symbol of good right?
But here it feels more like a
tombstone.
The moment they step inside,
this blast of unnatural cold
hits them, coming right from the
statue.
The foyer is dark, dead silent.
Then this massive winged shadow
zips across the wall and they
hear a loud hiss.
They find a dining hall that's
been completely trashed, and
then they find a Chapel, and
inside three figures in rusted
chainmail are just kneeling
silently before an altar.
So the party has stumbled from a
demonic chase to a mad Angel
right into the heart of
something else, and you just
know the silence in that Chapel
is about to be broken in the
worst way possible.
One of the adventurers decides
to use a little bit of magic to
just tap one of the Knights on
the shoulder.
Big mistake.
They stir, they rise. 3 skeletal
figures holding these tarnished
long swords turn to face the
party and their message is
simple and chilling.
Leave Radley.
The fighter steps up to take
them on.
The result is instant, and it is
savage.
He blocks one hit with his
magical shield, but his second
blow lands so hard at nearly
rattles his teeth out of his
head.
In that one moment, the whole
party realizes they cannot win
this.
This isn't a fight, it's a
slaughter waiting to happen.
They're forced into this
desperate fighting retreat out
of the Chapel.
It's only once they're safely
outside that the horrifying
truth dawns on them.
They weren't just fighting
skeletons, they were fighting
revenants.
These are undead spirits so
consumed by a need for revenge
that if you destroy their body,
their spirit just jumps into
another corpse and keeps coming.
You can't kill them.
You can't stop them.
Not until their mission is done.
And that is the terrifying new
reality for this party.
They've literally cheated death,
they've made a deal with a crazy
Angel, all to end up facing an
enemy that is basically
unkillable.
It leaves them and us with a
really chilling question.
How in the world do you defeat
an enemy that cannot truly die?